[Music]
hey before we let's go around the table
and say we're thankful for me I'm
thankful for Christian McCaffrey of
course my family but mostly Christian we
got messed up man all right Chad what
are you thankful for thank you for
asking
you're welcome but I'm thankful for the
comfort that this Adidas tracksuit
brings me of course we know they sponsor
you yeah that is true that is true man
but at Thanksgiving dinner what would
you rather be wearing none other than
that of an Adidas tracksuit we just ate
already I want to get to dessert
desserts what I'm thankful for
Oh what kind of dessert that's easy hey
I set myself up for that one about you
coach what do you thankful for well I
got a long list of things I'm thankful
for I love a good defensive line
I love some bone-crushing sex I like
bloody fistfights and I'll tell you what
I'm really thankful for Greta Gerwig
Little Women coming to theaters
everywhere December 25th
all right that's that's a lot of things
speed round baby let's go this tea is my
favorite what kind of tea is it check I
like tea I love tea especially when I'm
wearing my adidas Alfa is 40 shoe now
that's a sneaker did you even drink tea
- maybe I should get a pair to wear on
Christmas Day it's almost Christmas guys
you know what that means right
Olive won three fantasy championships by
then if we're lucky snow will be falling
from this first thing in the morning I
will be in line at the local cinema to
see Little Women
with Greta Gerwig and some other people
wait a minute is that an adidas
certified Turkey because nobody makes
turkey like the fine people at adidas I
got a show to do did call you want to
wrap this up noggin Hey well you guys
are messing around over there I already
ate five plates speed round eater guys
come on
all right maybe that's not quite the
speed round but thanks to Gordon
Ramsay's Papa thanks to you for joining
us on this Thanksgiving because it's
time for your fantasy fire drill
from the sports book it's Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill Thanksgiving edition
and here's your host the turkey with all
the gravy mad well don't worry about it
he wins today and so do you welcome to
your fantasy fire drill it is the
Thanksgiving episode I am your suburban
pilgrim Matt camp and we're gonna take
you through the three Thanksgiving Day
games don't worry we'll be back with you
on Sunday for our regular show 11:30
Eastern 8:30 Pacific on all bleach
report platforms now what are we gonna
do here today it's the three games we're
gonna give you who's up who's down and a
sleeper for all three games so you can
enjoy your Thanksgiving turkey and
hopefully a little fantasy football
production along the way let's jump into
that right now don't forget get your
questions in for Sunday's show and we'll
get to them along the way but right now
let's get to our questions our games I
should say for Thanksgiving we always
start Thanksgiving in Detroit I have
been to this game before I watched let's
say Peyton Manning throw for six
touchdowns like ten years ago
who will do so today it won't be
mitchell chor Biscay I don't care who's
playing quarterback for the Lions won't
happen there either but who is up who
was down and who was our sleeper for
this game it's time for a little stock
exchange on Thanksgiving we start with
the up who was up this week somebody I
think who could get busy this week
because he's taking on a very beatable
matchup in the Detroit Lions and that is
bears running back David Montgomery now
volume has been a problem for David
Montgomery but I think he'll get it in
this game because I think first of all
it's a very good matchup Detroit's been
one of the best matchup for fantasy
running backs really for the entire
season but especially over the last
month or so and I think look you want to
stay away from the Bears throwing the
ball too much they can throw in this
game but I think they'll control it for
the most part because of their defense
one of the best defense in the league
the record may not show it David
Montgomery could be in for 15 to 20
touches so I like David Montgomery rare
time I'm saying that but I think he gets
the volume today now we go to the down
part
we go to the other backfield and yeah I
did like him in week 12 I don't love
Bobo Scarborough against the Bears the
matchup is tough once again we have not
seen Detroit really fully commit to
anybody in this backfield we saw
Scarborough do it earlier I just don't
know if he's gonna get enough touches
for you to confidently play him in what
is a tougher matchup against the Chicago
Bears you got to wonder if the kiss it
could be more involved in this one
catching passes so I'm not super high on
Scarborough these are flex at best now
one sleeper for this game that I want
you to think about is to recall it now
Tariq Cohen as we look at a sleeper here
for this week is somebody who has been
more active as of late he's catching
passes out in the backfield he's found
the end zone and I think he's kind of
the safe receiver for a quarterback
situation that's not very ideal yeah we
love Alan Robinson and all the targets
he's getting but tarik Owens kind of
been the safety valve the security
blanket out of the backfield for the
Bears always can take it to the house
and if you're looking for a little
upside we want a little juice to go with
your turkey take a look at to reek : so
there you go there that is game number
one but we still have two more to go
including the late afternoon game the
Buffalo Bills in the Dallas Cowboys a
throwback Super Bowl matchup and a
matchup of two teams very likely heading
to the playoffs this year love talking
about that when it comes to the bills
but now more stock exchange for this
game up down and then we'll get to a
sleeper
Michael Gallup is going to lead us off
he is up this week and might be up for
the rest of season he's been up for a
couple of weeks now why do I like
Michael gal he's a heck of a player
number one he might be the guy I trust
the most of the Dallas Cowboys receiving
core we know Amari Cooper is trying to
play through injury he's been great at
doing that he's been terrible at doing
that but the bottom line is that
Prescott to me is playing at close to an
MVP level that means you can rely on
Michael gallop now I also think that
with the Marty Cooper out there he'll
probably draw the tougher matchups and
that is why Amari Cooper is down
now I'm not completely down on it like
to say you have to bench him but he's
playing through injury and I'm concerned
about this I told you a couple weeks ago
is a good idea to trade them I don't
like the matchup for him against the
Buffalo Bills I think he'll draw the
tougher matchups throughout the day
which is why trust Gallup more I'm a
little bit more leery of playing a Maury
Cooper and honestly the numbers really
aren't that far off so you have an up
you have it down both from Dallas but
we'll go to Buffalo now because we have
a sleeper for you in this game now the
sleepers are a tough spot why because
we're always looking for tight end help
we're gonna try to find it here then
dawson knox hasn't been super busy and
no I love John Brown the perfect wide
receiver to Beasley has been solid and
we've seen a bit of an up-and-down age
from Singletary in the backfield but
knocks a pretty good player has found
the endzone recently I think the targets
can pick up a little bit and the matchup
against the Cowboys says he should be
featured a bit more it's been a top ten
matchup for tight ends over the last
month so we're always looking for help a
tight end I talked about Dawson Knox in
week 12 I'll bring them up again here
this week so there you go Cowboys and
Bill's a throwback matchup and one that
has a lot of meanings on Thanksgiving
one more matchup the night game now I
remember last year vividly Thursday
Night Football Sean Payton really tried
to ruin our season hopefully he does not
do so again when the Falcons take on the
Saints two teams going obviously in
opposite directions but it is a
divisional matchup we get to your stock
exchange for this game right now who's
up and who's down and we'll get to a
sleeper in this game who's up first
who's up I like Jerry cook and Jerry
cooks been up for a few weeks now I know
the Falcons defense has been better
it doesn't necessarily scare me but the
return of Joo Brees has turned Jared
Cook not only back into a reliable
fantasy tight end but potentially a
top-five tight end for the rest of the
season
played well against the Falcons just a
couple of weeks ago in a game when the
Saints were not great and he's a
talented player it's just the breeze
injury cooks been banged up took a
little time to get going but I think
Jared cook is on his way up it could be
a top five option starting
with this Thanksgiving game now going
down we go to the other side of this
game I'm gonna tell you about Matt Ryan
now Ryan's been fine I think he's kind
of overcome what's been a bad season for
the Falcons and I also think that he's
been getting a lot of volume because
their defense has been playing that well
it's been playing better as of late Matt
Ryan just has been that good they're not
a great red zone offense the backfield
has been a mess as we know Austin
Hooper's been banged up yeah you have
Julio yell you have Calvin Ridley but I
just don't see Matt Ryan against this
Saints defense coming through with a
really strong week so he's a low-end
starter at best now one more you want a
sleeper we're gonna get you covered
right here you need a sleeper for your
Thanksgiving you might be even sleeping
at this time because it'll be so late in
the night after all the turkey that you
may have consumed and I like latavius
Murray why I think game flow will go in
favor of the New Orleans Saints now
chimera is back he's rolling there's no
concern I talked to him a couple weeks
ago he loves playing in this tandem
latavius Murray but I think from a game
flow standpoint the Saints could control
it late in the game you let him run it
out while the Murray who by the way when
in doubt get a piece of a good team the
Saints are one of the best in football
if I'm throwing this guy and there's a
flex I feel pretty confident he'll come
through for you there you go you had a
little turkey you're getting ready for
the games and now you got your fantasy
lineup set with some confidence but
don't worry this is a Thanksgiving
episode I'll be back with you on Sunday
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific right here at
Caesars in the sports book for your
fantasy fire drill make sure you get
your questions in there check out the
sleepers article coming out on Friday
for all the games my mailbag on Friday
and of course I'll be right back here so
get your questions in to get them
answered for week 13 and beyond we're
making a run towards the fantasy
playoffs you'll get it done right here
i'm matt camp we'll see you on Sunday
for your fantasy fire drill
[Music]